[Música]
eu pra quem é engajado pela literatura
falar sobre a transformação é
simplesmente tudo é eu penso que a gente
teve oportunidade de neste dia de hoje é
tratada transformação sob vários
aspectos
agora os aspectos da transformação e eu
queria convidar vocês a falar comigo
nesses minutos sobre a transformação sob
essa perspectiva da palavra é a gente
teve acabei de ouvir um relato né sobre
uma uma transformação que se iniciou com
a leitura de um livro e é sobre isso que
eu queria falar sobre como a leitura
transforma a vida das pessoas
a gente está aqui um evento o evento
dentro de uma universidade e acredito
que a maioria das pessoas que estão aqui
sabem da importância da leitura é como
esse vetor de transformação como um
caminho para a transformação
só que dentro de si dessa grande desse
grande nicho desse grande segmento que a
gente tomou tratar de uma maneira muito
danificada que a leitura
gostaria de fazer um recorte com vocês
dentro desse segmento que a leitura
literária não é uma leitura que você
está fazendo para sua formação dentro da
universidade
não essa leitura pra você ter um de
incentivo é uma outra leitura sintonizar
nessa leitura da ficção
na leitura que a gente lê é pra entreter
nosso espírito nossa alma pra fazer uma
sintonia fina conosco mesmo né pra falar
dos nossos medos para ter contato com
outras histórias que vão falar é com
aquilo que nós temos de mais íntimo
antes de nós que a literatura enquanto
arte hoje está passando por um momento
muito delicado no brasil uma situação
meio é difícil e por isso que achei bem
apropriado o tema da transformação
eu acho que hoje em dia
descansa num cenário assim com um
desemprego na casa dos parece presa 14
milhões de empregados
a gente tá meio uma lagarta rastejam né
a gente nem aquela borboleta na cruzada
e ainda e eu acredito muito que a
universidade que a leitura e sobretudo a
literatura ea arte são fundamentais
nesse caminho pra gente sair de onde
está esse lugar tão incômodo e por que
que eu acredito nisso é é no fundo aqui
eu vou passar algumas imagens do meu do
meu cotidiano de trabalho
eu sou um autor sobretudo de literatura
para crianças e jovens eu tenho alguns
trabalhos que são para adultos mas
sobretudo para crianças e jovens
a gente tem o brasil muito esse desejo
que a gente se torne eleitor de que uma
leitura literária de ler livros de
histórias de ficção
agora porque eu pergunto a vocês porque
tem esse desejo porque há grandes
políticas públicas de incentivo à
leitura é porque é porque é eu vou há
muitas escolas é falar com crianças bem
pequenas com jovens leitores não existe
esse desejo de transformar o brasil num
país mesmo de leitores porque isso
justamente porque a palavra tem esse
poder de transformar nossa realidade é
especialmente a letra de ter a área
porque a palavra chão é base porque onde
um livro acontece dentro de nós não é
dentro da nossa imaginação dentro do
nosso sentimento então livro tem esse
poder de catar se o sentimento no seu
mais pino é uma sintonia fina não é
então adélia prado ela já esteve aqui né
na cidade também já falou isso já pôde
ouvir lula disse isso ela fala que a mãe
dela não pôde deixar uma grande herança
não pode deixar para ela é patrimônio às
vezes um curso mas se o pai a mãe pois é
o de deixar seu filho sentimento o
sentimento ea sensibilidade e se a coisa
mais fina do mundo é a coisa de mais
valor com o sentimento pode ter é um que
um ser humano pode ter
é o sentimento é a sensibilidade com o
outro um próximo a empatia ea literatura
é um caminho pra gente refinar o nosso
sentimento nossa sentir da mesma dela
uma outra frase muito bonita o ons e
reproduzir com as mesmas palavras que é
tem dia que deus me tira poesia e pedra
é pedra só e vejo a pedra a pedra só
pedra olha que vida dura a vida de quem
não tem literatura de quem não tem
poesia de quem não tem arte na vida é
uma vida muito áspera difícil de lidar
no seu cotidiano então é por isso que é
uma bandeira na minha vida não é levar a
literatura e fazer essa distinção entre
ler e estudar entre a informação entre
leitura e sucesso entre leitura é
prosperidade financeira e econômica
você pode ser mais graças à dos seres
humanos mas você tem no o sentimento
dentro de você você está salva
você tem esse refinamento do sentir sob
tal você vai encontrar outro caminho só
vai encontrar um livro no seu caminho
você vai ter sensibilidade para estar
aqui um sábado como hoje o mundo o outro
ter essa paciência de ouvir o outro não
é é preciso fazer se esse recorte porque
a gente costuma ter essa preocupação em
ler para estudar ele para se formar
mas a leitura sem expor as plásticas no
brasil as pessoas não lenda pois formam
então tem muito uma uma conclusão que
lei estudar ler não é só estudar ler
muito mais do que estudar é contar
escutar uma boa história muito mais
antiga escola é muito mais antiga
universidade muito mais importantes
manteve houve um fim do mundo e qualquer
né
a última bomba atômica vai acabar tudo
né vai ficar as baratas escorpiões
contador de história não é uma coisa que
não acaba
é a ficção é praticamente instrutivo não
importa o suporte que ela esteja a tiago
livro de papel vai acabar no seu que eu
li o livro tem isso não está em risco
pode ser que um suporte esteja em risco
mas o livro o livro de ficção em si não
está mas voltando aqui que eu tenho uma
leve a jada é eu queria fazer voltar na
importância tão voltando eu estou
falando com vocês a importância de ler
literatura desse você já um leitor de
literatura de ser um agente é propagador
dessa leitura literária e de como essa
leitura literária ela é eficiente e
somente safra que esse negócio voltando
e é é escritor e tem muitos negócios e
de você também ser um divulgador e
eficiente da literatura como é como um
fator transformador de promover esse
encontro da literatura com as pessoas
porque porque a gente tem uma média de
leitura muito baixo no brasil então as
pessoas vão entender o que a literatura
é um exemplo muitas vezes tomou um táxi
entrou no táxi táxi são geralmente o
taxista uma pessoa curiosa que é também
aqui que se faça ou escrevo escritora
escrevente da polícia falando não é
escritor sabe o que faz livro a livro na
escola geografia história não mostre
literatura sabe ter a turma que célestin
pra b porque porque a literatura é tão
subjetivo
do campo da arte é uma coisa tão é que
não é palpável que não tem se a asma é
uma coisa objetiva da utilidade dessa
coisa do utilitarismo que fica quase
difícil para as pessoas entenderem
então se você é uma pessoa que está
distante disso te convido a se aproximar
desse campo da arte né e se você é um
leitor de literatura que você traga mais
pessoas para integrar tudo porque porque
a literatura transforma essa nossa
realidade agora dura que a gente está
atravessando né é que as pessoas não
conseguem entender o alcance que tem na
vida das pessoas como a mãe da adélia
prado é sabidamente de sangue lan
quando a gente tem às vezes as
universidades sob ameaça de corte está
vivendo agora então falta essa
sensibilidade para entender como
investimento na arte é importante a
gente está passando por um momento muito
sério então acho que eu que pinçou bi e
se o convite né
convidado para falar que como um autor
eu não posso me furtar a dívida
seriedade no momento que está passando
né que a cultura está sob sobre um
ataque um deputado assim né pra cultura
ó acho que não precisa investir muito
isso não porque a gente não tem um
retorno é imediato né por parte da
cultura e é mentira porque a cultura ela
transforma individualmente as pessoas
coletivamente as pessoas e isso tem um
efeito prático a nossa realidade o que
thiago reduza a violência aumenta a
tolerância entre as pessoas
não é é é e faz encontrar um caminho
interno se resolve as pessoas é
internamente se ajuda nessa construção
ou nessas questões se eu tenho uma
pessoa um pouco melhor
eu acredito que eu vou saber ele está
com o próximo é o tempo está acabando
com um relógio que na frente da gente
e ao gol então entrar num outro assunto
que é o porquê da palavra escrita ser
tão importante e esse exercício de
literatura ea palavra escrita tão
importante
então vamos pensar hoje a gente vive num
mundo tão tecnológico eu separei algumas
fotos não são fotos é desses encontros
não é com esses leitores jovens e que eu
digo pra eles que estão sempre com o
celular na mão todos têm facebook tem a
tap não sei o que nem sempre estão
envolvidos como a mídia
eles têm muito pouca paciência para é a
magia da palavra escrita para acessar
esse mundo porque a literatura é
exigente acho que a gente tem que fazer
alguns mitos aqui que ele trata o menu é
velhinha base em conta a história
entendeu no entanto não é isso
a literatura ela vai te levar por
caminhos vários tamanhos amigos escuros
também não é bom os caminhos maus
caminhos da literatura
ela é sobretudo feita da palavra escrita
seca assim mesmo sem apelo nenhum então
é aquele momento íntimo é seu com aquele
livro ea partir dali e sem nenhum outro
recurso de imagem e de som da asm team
mídia assim você vai ter que realizar
aquele livro dentro de você
tanto do ponto de vista sem da imagem
não é você vai criar aquelas imagens
criar aqueles personagens como também do
sentimento então se você ler um livro
que chamou só nó que criou sensações e
sentimentos
penso também que é importante o impacto
que isso tem na vida das pessoas
por isso que a palavra escrita é tão
poderosa porque mexe muito com a nossa
imaginação com a nossa criatividade
porque nos torna criadores
então eu costumo brincar que o livro é
meio que uma planta baixa da conta de
uma construção
é a gente vai seguir aquela instrução
que está naquele livro vai criar aquele
universo daquele livro o universo pode
ser romper em saque de fantasia vai ser
aqueles personagens aquele cenário
o universo é emocional psicólogo
psicólogo esta vai ser a clarice
lispector por exemplo vai entrar naquele
mundo psicológico feminino
então esse é o poder da palavra o risco
que a palavra é tão importante porque se
elas subsidiar a nossa imaginação
pensem vocês nós somos seres da
imaginação
se a gente foi até a lua bem antes pela
literatura anos já tínhamos ido até lá
uri isso que a literatura e leitura
literária é tão fundamental porque tudo
que nos cerca antes foi imaginado por
alguém absolutamente tudo
então eu quando machuca o hospital
eu prefiro ser atendido por um médico
eleitor porque porque ele pode ou com
certeza será um médico muito mais
é criativo com muito mais a imaginação
olha que a menina olha o livro uma
parcela dessas crianças quando eu vou
uma escola elas ler um livro
uma parcela de 10% uma leia o livro de
verdade chega pra mim falar em seu livro
muito legal eu me emocionei e tudo
outra parte não leu os outros 10% leram
então esse é o problema que a gente tem
que enfrentar entendeu que a gente quer
fazer alguma coisa efetiva porque quando
eu vim falar sobre transformação aqui eu
penso em efetivamente ter transformação
isso aqui é uma escola em paulista é 20
quilotons do recife no pernambuco
quando eu vou falar com essas crianças
onde na vídeo tudo charretes carroças
bicicleta morre de medo mas me chamar
hugo chávez também em paulista paulista
no interior de são paulo
não aqui no pernambuco a nossa senhora
ba diz né só de um vôo de nova york não
é quando chega lá poste em vôo o porquê
porque eu acho que se eu se dessa turma
que eu tô conversando se eu conseguir
promover esse encontro com a literatura
já vai ter valido a viagem se dali eu
consegui formar um leitor já terá valido
viagem
já como é que forma o leitor é com esse
encontro com do votava no início eu
estava falando com o sentimento
você leu o livro e deu aqui ó o calor no
coração foi que ele teve
então aí aquele aquela pessoa vai ser um
leitor porque ela teve um encontro em
álcool a literatura
aquele encontro que teve uma experiência
com a literatura que ressignifica
ressignifica o livro pra ela
o livro vai ter um outro significado na
vida daquela pessoa
então a leitura o livro vai passar a
fazer parte dela com uma coisa
importante não com uma coisa que eu
olhei no chelsea tiro que um mantém uma
biblioteca na minha casa então é e
gostaria de fechar dizendo isso
relembrar a importância do livro e da
leitura como um fator é importante
decisivo na transformação da sociedade e
que a gente passa o nosso esforço
individual não fica esperando só ações
distantes de políticas públicas de um
livro para quem você gosta hoje deixa
amanhã é isso
[Música]